CCSD teachers address lawmakers today
about the issues within the district and
the state of education overall this
happened during a town hall at Sunrise
Mountain High School Joshua peguero
Joins us live in The Newsroom tonight
with more from that meeting and Joshua
what did you just tell you the teachers
from the Clark County Education
Association which organized this event
say the staff shortages at a crisis the
district needs more than 14 000
Educators addressing nearly two dozen
lawmakers teachers say the state hasn't
made a real investment in building a
future Workforce
a lot of our students don't have those
licensed staff members in the classroom
and that's impacting their their
learning and their performance besides
serving as a ccea board member Jordan
Wenger is a school psychologist at Clyde
Cox and Paul culley elementary schools
she supports recent moves by CCSD to
partner with Nevada State College and
UNLV to help pay for the tuition of
future teachers as a step in the right
direction it's uh removing a lot of
barriers for people becoming Educators
so they could get a lot of that student
loan forgiveness tcsd lost more teachers
in the 2021-2022 school year the most it
ever has especially in the last five six
years so many educators are leaving
teachers talk to lawmakers about the
need for funding Nevada changed its
education funding formula to Target
struggling schools but the teachers
union is concerned over Governor Joe
Lombardo's emphasis on giving parents
more power to choose what what type of
school they send their children to a
position that stays Senate Majority
Leader Nicole kanazaro criticized
[Music]
other teachers also Express frustration
on the violence in the classroom they
say there's a lack of counselors and
social workers in schools to help deal
with it well I think we just need more
funding to train teachers in restorative
practices so that we know how to deal
with children who are experiencing those
type of behaviors and especially our
children with mental health issues
school safety has also been a concern in
CCSD during the
2021-2022 school year more than 8 000
behavioral reports among students were
recorded seven thousand of them were
acts of violence with 667 being battery
of a School employee reporting in The
Newsroom Joshua baguero eight news now
the ccea also says the structure of
school board governance needs to change
calling the current Board of Trustees a
quote dysfunctional model